OMER MAHMOOD: Hey, Mark.
How's it going?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey, Omer.
I'm just waiting on these
deep machine learning models
to train using TensorFlow,
but it's taking forever.
Do you know any way we could
possibly speed them up?
OMER MAHMOOD: Sure.
Well, one approach is to
use Tensor Processing Units,
or TPUs, that enable
you to train and run
predictions on
TensorFlow machine
learning models
faster than ever.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK.
Sounds pretty good.
But what exactly is a TPU?
I've heard of GPUs.
But what does a
TPU do differently?
OMER MAHMOOD: Well
here, let me show you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Here we have a comparison
of a GPU and TPU.
The modern GPU usually has 2,500
to 5,000 arithmetic logic units
in a single processor.
That means you could execute
thousands of multiplications
and additions simultaneously.
But the GPU is still a
general-purpose processor
that has to support millions
of different applications
and software.
This means that for
every single calculation,
the GPU needs to access
registers, or shared memory,
to read and store the
intermediate calculation
results, causing a bottleneck.
TPUs can't run word processors,
control rocket engines,
or execute bank transactions.
But they can handle massive
multiplications and additions
for neural networks at
blazingly fast speeds
while consuming much less power
and inside a smaller physical
footprint.
So let's look at
actually setting one up.
First, we need to launch a Cloud
Shell in the Cloud console.
We're going to use a TPU tool.
Run the following command
to set up a Compute Engine
virtual machine and a Cloud
TPU with associated services.
This combination of
resources and services
is called a Cloud TPU flock.
You can use a CTPU up command
and the output message.
The name is the name of
your TPU resource, which
defaults to your
username, and the zone
is a default geographic zone
for your Compute Engine.
Once created, the CTPU
command connects us
to the compute instance
with Cloud TPU attached.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK, great.
So we have a TPU, but how do
we check that everything's
up and running?
OMER MAHMOOD: Good question.
We're going to test the
environment by executing
a simple TensorFlow script.
This script is read
in Python and performs
a simple computation.
Let's run that script now.
Of course, you don't want to
leave these resources running,
so you'd better make sure to
spin them down when we're done.
First, we'll disconnect
from the Compute Engine VM
with the exit command.
Then we'll run this
command to delete
the VM and its
associated cloud TPU--
CTPU delete.
And then add the
name of your VM.
TPUs are specifically made
to make matrix calculations
faster.
So you definitely
want to attach them
to any VM that is used
for machine learning.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Don't forget
to subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]